[Music]
Oh
good morning New York City
[Music]
what are you doing what's it look like
I'm doing I'm doing superhero stuff I'm
calling this meeting of the superhero
animal friends to order come on Molly
time to go I'm gonna be late for school
captain snowball you're in charge while
I'm gone one first of all I want to
welcome right Thunder back from the
washing machine who was put in there
with a red blanket and hate sports will
be known as pick thunder personally I
like the new look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no hmm why is there lampshade on your
head my owner might have given me a
little bit of cat okay do you hear that
Oh your party oh I wonder what other
sounds I could make
are you finished hi I'm home let's say
we go for a walk this is nice first time
here uh yeah
Oh dr. Francis is the best veterinarian
in the business you're gonna love him he
specializes in behavioral disorders but
I don't have a behavioral disorder I I'm
fine too it's by human that's nuts I
mean you know I I bring him a dead bird
she throws it out I bring him a dead
mouse garbage and I've gone no no my
owner always says you're such a good dog
and I feel like a good dog of us what if
deep down I'm a bad dog bad dog we start
fires that was weird
Oh sister it's gonna get way weirder
[Music]